I got 10 000 people to promote my next
book 100 million dollar leads absolutely
free and to give you a visual of that
that's like an entire Stadium full of
people promoting your thing and now
imagine those people leaving that
stadium and then entering their own
individual stadiums and shouting being
like go check this thing out and the
best part is it's absolutely free I was
thinking to myself like what would be
the craziest way that I could launch
this book to make a big Fanfare about it
because my first book 100 million dollar
offers was all about making a crazy
offer to people as in making an offer so
good people feel stupid saying no and I
tried to make the book A meta example of
the concept within the book I talk about
having elements to enhance the offer
having a big price to Value discrepancy
and so I offer the book for 99 cents but
included a course which most people
would charge thousands of dollars for
absolutely free without even asking
people to opt in for it all of this was
just to demonstrate the value equation
which was the core concept of that book
now my 100 million dollar leads book is
a different book it's about advertising
in order to get leads and so I was like
okay well if I wanted to demonstrate all
the concepts in that book I'd have to do
something totally different than how I
did with offers and so with this I was
like well how do I show that can get
lots of leads with a book and so I was
like I'm gonna hold a big book event so
I'm going to hold a book launch event
it's me virtual and it's going to be
free and everyone's invited and I'm
going to see how many people I can get
to this thing and I'm not going to do it
the way I could do it which would just
be like I could post it on my social
media I probably get plenty of people to
go I wanted to use every single one of
the methods I talk about in the book to
promote the book itself and one of those
methods is called affiliate marketing
and so the way that I actually did this
in the real world was that we created an
affiliate opt-in which is just put your
name your email your phone number and
then what we would give them is a unique
URL so a custom link that if someone
clicked their link it would take them to
the leads opt-in page for the event but
it would be tracked back to them and
then the top 10 Affiliates I said I
would hop on a live q a call with their
audience if they won and they were in
the top 10. anyone who got at least 10
people to show up to the event I would
give two bonus chapters for my book that
I'm not going to release with the book
as an added benefit and if you think
about this it's because I want to
incentivize the highest Affiliates to
promote the most and become competitive
but I don't want somebody who has like a
hundred percent email list to think oh
I'm never going to win that why bother
well there's also a prize that everyone
can win there's scarcity at the top but
then just a tiny hurdle for everyone
which is actually one of the strategies
I talk about when creating an affiliate
compensation system because it actually
works the same way whether you're
promoting an event or supplements or
Widgets or Services it all works the
same way so inside this video I'm going
to talk about who to pick to affiliate
with how to onboard them properly and
set expectations how to get them to
start advertising and how to keep them
advertising along the way and a little
bonus of how to structure that off all
right so the first thing that you have
to figure out when you're creating an
affiliate strategy or influencer
strategies who's the ideal affiliate one
of the more advanced advertising
strategies is that you actually have two
customers now you have your affiliate
Avatar and then you have your customer
Avatar so now it means that you have to
deliver to two types of people rather
than one and that's where it gets more
complicated if you're starting out that
being said there's different ways of
doing this in different Industries for
example if I'm a brick and mortar
business my affiliate strategy is let's
say I'm a massage person I could then go
and say okay what are all the big
businesses in the area and say okay
these guys hire 10 new employees a week
it's a big Corporation I say hey Mr
Corporation I want to give each of your
new employees two free massages on the
house here's a coupon you can give it to
them in their new employee packet why
would that business say no to giving
their employees some sort of treat and
for me I'm happy to just get new
customers and if I make that partnership
now with 10 or 100 companies then I'm
going to be able to fill up my books and
how much did that cost me in advertising
literally only the effort to reach out
to them and make the ask right and so
you have with an affiliate strategy two
levels of offers what's the offer you're
going to make them and then what's the
offer they're going to make on your
behalf to their customers right and so
the two free massages is my cut is my
offer to their customer which in this
place is an employee which totally
underrated strategy because they'll
never see you as competition but then
also why am I going to make this offer
to the employer the offer to them is
your employees will like you more and
have a better onboarding experience and
be de-stressed by having this thing and
you'll be perceived as a more caring
employer that's the offer I don't need
to like incentivize them and pay them or
do anything like that because it's in
their best interest to the same degree
if I'm still that massage therapist I
might go to a chiropractor and say hey
some of your people get their backs
cracked and they probably need someone
to massage anybody who gets their back
crack with you I'll give them a massage
on the house and then all of a sudden
that chiropractor gets 50 new patients a
month will send you a certain percentage
of those patients now you could also
even pay them on top of that to further
incentivize them but typically if you do
a really good job and you establish a
relationship they'll start doing that
and if you're really smart about it
you'll start referring them business too
and then that is where you really start
the machine going that's a brick and
mortar example an influencer example is
probably what most people are used to
which is like hey use my discount code
for 10 off and then the influencer gets
some Kickback now sometimes that's just
a straight endorsement you pay them to
post which is much more like paid
advertising or you do some sort of split
based on what they bring you which is
much closer to affiliate advertising
which is what I'm talking about a third
version of this is the main way that I
used to Market this book which is
affiliate marketing which is much more
common in the internet marketing world
this covers a huge amount of people who
have lists and audiences that they have
trust with what you have to do is say
Hey you will gain trust with your
audience the trade is that sometimes
they do lose trust with their audience
which is why people pay to get
Affiliates ultimately your brand matters
a lot with why they would trust their
customers and their Goodwill with you
and so the reason in my opinion that the
book launch which is not here but
pretend I have my book right here has
gone well using the strategy is that
many people in my audience trust that
I'm going to over deliver which I
absolutely am to Their audience and so
Their audience will then associate the
value they get from me with them and so
it's almost like them getting free
Goodwill by promoting my stuff right and
that's what you want the crazy part
about the affiliate strategy that I'm
going to outline for you is that I
actually have zero Financial incentive
which is not common most the time if you
go to a social media you know you get
some influencer and you're like hey will
you promote my supplement brand they're
like well what's my split right because
they're like I'm going to be taking some
Goodwill out of my audience so I need to
be compensated for that but if you have
such Goodwill you might do it for free
if you actually thought that it was good
I mean think about when a friend of
yours is like hey what pair of shoes are
those you're like oh love these shoes or
I love this bag or whatever it is you're
being an affiliate just in a micro with
your micro influence to that business
and you do it because you feel like you
will actually gain in relational Capital
because that person will go buy the
shoes use the shoes love the shoes tell
you about it associate with you that's
why you do it the affiliate strategy
that I learned from my process was
simple I have two layers of Affiliates
and I think this is useful for anyone
when you're thinking about your products
or your business is that I've got my
super affiliate level and then I've got
regular Affiliates the key difference is
that I like to have two polar opposite
strategies the people who are super
Affiliates have big audiences and they
tend to be competitive more status
driven Etc and so I want to align what
they want which is status with what I
want which is people what I decided to
do was say hey and this is going to be
pretty key and I haven't I haven't
explained this publicly yet so you know
enjoy I said the top 10 will get an AMA
live with me to Their audience now
here's why this is unique and different
one I have a very small supply of time
like I don't speak in public very much I
think in the last year of companies that
I don't own I've done one speech I try
and limit my supply of time that I'm
available to other people's audiences
imagine you're now in the audience of
this super affiliate and he says Hey
register for this book of it now if I'm
the customer or on that person's
audience I think what's in it for me why
don't I just go to Alex's thing rather
than clicking your link or why do I
click your link for someone else's well
here's why this benefits them so if I'm
the affiliate I say hey click my link so
that our community can have the prize
rather than me saying hey the top 10
Affiliates get supercars right because
why does that benefit Their audience
because if I did if I did it exactly
that hey let me help me win my contest
that is withdrawing from Their audience
but if I do it this way then I can say
hey I actually want to support you in
your audience and that way when you make
this email to your list it doesn't cost
you anything and so that's why I
engineered it this way so that this is
just Goodwill they gain and the reason
why is aligned so that their incentive
my incentive and the audiences that are
all aligned towards the same outcome
which is to get the click and sign up
for the event so whenever you're making
something for any affiliate you want to
align all of the incentives to the
greatest degree possible now when you
say I'm just going to pay them that
aligns your incentive and their
incentive but not the audience's
incentive and so the more aligned
incentives you get the bigger the
outcome now the second level is regular
affiliate so if you're like okay well
right now I think the top people all
have like a thousand people that they've
sent over to uh the book launch for us
and so if you have a thousand total
followers the likelihood that you're
going to send all thousand is probably
pretty low and so you might be like well
why even bother so you have to answer
that question which is why I have the
second tier so why bother even
affiliating to begin with why bother
even promoting this I said if you get
more than 10 to show up to the event
just 10 people and if you have an email
list or you have any following
whatsoever even if you don't have any of
those things you just know 10 people who
you think it would be valuable you don't
have to have any marketing skills to get
10 people to a thing and the reason you
would do it remember aligned incentives
is that they trust that if I say hey
this is going to be worth it I'm going
to deliver on that and the reason they
might be able or willing to make that
bet is because if I've said it in the
past that it would be worth it I have
delivered on that and so give you a bit
of context I've only emailed my list I
think like three or four times in the
past year and I've made a lot of content
we put out 250 a week a thousand pieces
of content a month so 12 000 a year
right roughly in terms of pieces of
content and only four pieces of content
that I say I think you guys should go
check this out it's worth the time right
not to say I don't think the other time
is worth it but if I'm going to make the
ask I want to make sure that whatever
they get is far in excess because let's
say every piece of content 80 of people
think it's good and 20 of people think
it's mid whatever okay but if I know
that 99 of people are going to believe
that it's going to be amazing then
that's one where I have a low risk of
saying hey you're going to get more than
your time by doing this or by watching
this and so from the big picture
perspective when you're promoting this
you don't want to like smash everyone
all at once the whole time because then
people get sick of you right the best
analogy I've heard from this is
something called whisper T shout and I
heard this somewhere at some event and I
don't know who originally came up with
it but I just love this you've got
whisper T shout and this is really like
the three phases of promoting anything
so whisper is where you drip itty bit
like not even hints you're just building
anticipation and so this is like the
Godzilla scene in the movie theaters
that's just like the foot and it's just
says may 2025 right and so they don't
tell you the plot there's no character
development it's just enough to get you
excited that's all it is within the
context of this book
over the last two years I've just been
sprinkling little stories maybe like up
another day of riding another like just
oh got another thing I got something
good for you like and I'm just showing
just not a lot not saying what's inside
of it not talking at all about the
contents just saying I'm writing a book
and there's some and it's going to be
good you guys are going to love it right
and showing the work because let me give
you a quick example on this is that if I
said I spent two years making this 10
minute video How likely would it be that
you think that video was good compared
to I said hey I spent two hours on this
10 minute video you'd probably be way
more likely to watch the 10 minute video
that I spent two years working on and so
the same thing works with whatever
projects you want to sell the further
out you can show them that you're
working on this thing the more they'll
believe that you have invested in it and
I learned this from an early mentor of
mine he said the key to making it a big
deal is to make it a big deal and so
like it doesn't matter what you're doing
if you tell people that something's a
big deal then they will believe that
it's a big deal and so I can't say it
more simply than that and so if I show
you that I've been working on this for
two years then when I say it's finally
ready people be like wow he's worked a
long time on this I want to check it out
so you build curiosity here we
transition to the t-space let me let me
walk you through so phase one is six
weeks plus out that means like three
months out 12 months two years out
you're just Whispering that's all we're
doing here then we get into teasing so
this is where you you peel back a corner
of the page and you and you show one
page or you do a reading of a paragraph
or you make videos about some of the
content right that's inside the book now
you don't show the whole thing you just
zoom in on a little bit just just a clip
just a little something something so
they're like now I have a prediction of
what type of value I'm going to get from
this thing right now you're looking at
the trailer right that's 30 seconds long
that has a couple dinosaurs running in
and out you're like oh there's there's
action in this like you get a general
direction of what this movie is going to
be about this is six weeks to seven days
then you transition to shout shout is
the last seven days leading up into the
thing at this point you're not
whispering you're not teasing you're not
hinting you're like this is the thing
it's gonna be awesome be there and most
of this is reminders a big part that
most people mess up and this is what I
see a lot of marketers do overall is
they spend six weeks shouting right
people literally get bored of your thing
before before it even happens because
you've talked about it so much right so
that's number one and you want it to be
a you want it to feel like this it's
like intermittent intermittent more
frequent and then you Crescendo up into
whatever the event is right and you get
big lots of money there you go all right
when we're in the shout phase how
effective you are at the shout is
actually predicted by everything you did
before that and so what happens is most
people don't provide enough value before
they say hey I've got my thing right and
so what they have to do is they start
having to artificially create value and
increase their content frequency in
order to approximate having provided
value beforehand and so they try and
provide value and ask and provide value
and ask at the same time and it just
looks disjointed because they don't have
any good will to withdraw from and so
then they ask and Shout even harder and
louder until eventually no one listens
to them you don't want that we want to
be really careful about when we're
shouting it is super effective but then
you burn it out quickly and so you want
to use it right here so it leads to the
event during the whisper and tease phase
this is something that my brain director
and I Caleb had a long discussion about
which is during these time periods are
we going to only talk about the book
it's like well no what about during the
cheese phase are we only going to talk
about the book no we're going to still
provide value the exact same way we have
been in the exact same volume we have
been and then added it on top so think
about that you're like wait that sounds
like more work sure is
my team's behind the cameras this way
the idea though is that why would I want
to decrease the value that I'm providing
my audience during the time when I want
to ask them to do something even more
it's like no not only do I want to make
sure that I'm providing my regular value
which is about business content in
general growing businesses scaling sales
marketing Etc but then I also want to
talk about the book and if you want to
be clever with it whenever you're making
your advertisements because this is an
advertisement it just means making other
people know about your stuff that's what
I'm doing right you want to still make
sure that the advertisement itself is
still valuable like who here likes going
to the movie theater and then watching
the trailers I love watching the
trailers before a movie like I'm bummed
if I don't get the first 15 minutes
before the movie why because they are
valuable they're entertaining I like
watching them and so there's a reason
they design them that way people share
trailers why because it's valuable and
if you share the trailer what did it do
you got more people to find out about it
which is why well-designed
advertisements provide value to the
person and let them know about the thing
that's the magic throughout this whole
process if you think about value as this
line This is constant all the way
through it it's unchanging all right so
we're providing value the whole time and
then we sprinkle in whisper whisper then
we start showing more details about what
they're going to find out the value that
they're going to get and then we remind
we remind we remind until the event
meanwhile still posting value still
adding to the audience so that each of
these hit because think about this every
day you have new people who come into
your world and they don't have two years
of Goodwill so I have probably more
people coming to my world right now
because so many more people are
promoting my book that I actually have
to deliver more value than I ever have
because I have so many new people who
are now going to find out about my stuff
and what a shame it would be if they
enter my world and then the only thing
they have is a smash for me saying go
grab something go check out my virtual
event right so I have to be delivering
in higher amounts because I have more
people than ever who are seeing your
stuff right that's the idea and that is
the whole concept between the
three-phase attack of whisper tease
shout and for everyone who wants to use
paid influencers paid Affiliates
endorsements I have tons of money
examples costs and returns how to
calculate it how to set what percentages
for what tiers of Affiliates how to set
up multiple tiers how much value I put
in each one have all of those and all
the best practices that I've used inside
of here I didn't want to include in this
video not because I don't want to share
it because I think a lot of people get
lost in the numbers and you probably
want to read and reread it again in
front of you which is why it's in the
book so if this is interesting you're
like man I would love to find a way that
other businesses could advertise my
stuff on my behalf and do it for free or
do it only after I've made money so
there's no risk to me then Affiliates
are your play so let's talk about the
actual mechanics of this all right so
for me because I didn't have to do
payouts it became significantly easier
for me to get Affiliates all right right
because typically when you have an
affiliate there's two ways to do it you
can have paid and unpaid So Paid
Affiliates either pay them with money or
you scratch their back they scratch your
back right this is the collab this is
the I'll promote your thing if you
promote my thing now for me I don't feel
confident that I could promote a lot of
my affiliate stuff just being really
candid because I don't know if they're
necessarily at that level yet or I
wouldn't risk the trust that I have
built with my audience just being very
candid but they're not asking me to do
that so that's okay now on the unpaid
side they have to get other things and
that's where I'm adding those extra
bonuses in in order to get them to want
to do it when you have a paid affiliate
you have to get them to fill out all
these forms taxes
so that you can pay them and they can be
seen as uh I don't even remember what it
is maybe it's a K1 or a 1099 I think
it's a 1099 they get a 1099 from your
company because they all have sent you
money and then you have to send them
money back and there's all these forms
you have to have them fill out now the
good thing with this is that if someone
goes to the trouble of doing this
they'll likely that they want to promote
a significantly higher so there are
benefits this if I'm in a B2B business
all day long I want to have a little bit
more friction I want to qualify the
affiliate I want to make sure that
they're sending the right types of
people to whatever it is that I have
especially if I'm selling services now I
have a book which is delivered without
my time and so I'm willing to forego
some of the friction that I would
normally put it with a B2B business in
order to get more scale and volume in a
b2c scenario so for here the way the
opt-in form worked for our affiliate
campaign if you've if you want to check
it out you can go to acquisition.com
forward slash affiliate and what you'll
see is you'll see a first name last name
email phone and that's it and you'll see
a button when they click that the thank
you page and we did it in two ways the
thank you page has their now custom link
that they can use to promote your thing
and they get an email because sometimes
people lose it or they don't screenshot
or whatever that also has a copy of that
this sounds like tiny stuff but
sometimes like the extra email or
putting on the thank you page makes a 25
difference in the amount of people who
promote your stuff and as a side benefit
here we actually changed the banner on
top of the submit form and increase the
amount of Affiliates who decided to sign
up on the opt-in Page by 60 all right
and so little things can still make huge
differences in the Campaign which is why
I'm sharing these tiny details with you
now when you want the Affiliates to sign
up if you want volume you make it easier
if you want quality you make it harder
and the push-pull in business is
figuring out where the sweet spot is for
your for your products at your price
point I'm going really Mass market for a
book which is considered probably a
pretty cheap thing all right and so I
can go all the way on this side and then
I'm trying to make this as easy as
simply possible so like how long does it
take to sign up to be an affiliate of
the book 30 seconds and literally
someone can go 30 seconds and then make
a story on social media and immediately
share it and get leads right so I made
it really low time delay remember the
value equation we can still apply it to
every step in this whole process so the
value is they become an affiliate the
time delay is 30 seconds the effort and
sacrifices they type their stuff in and
the perceived likely that it works is
they click submit and if it works
they're done right so we still apply the
same four variables to every step in
this process to get the most amount of
people to promote your stuff now from
your promotional aspects there are two
big promotions that you'll be running
concurrently again remember I said
there's two types of customers well that
means that I'm running marketing
campaigns to the customers who I want to
show up to the event and I'm also now
running campaigns to the Affiliates to
remind them to promote the vet right
because once you get the affiliate
that's the easy part the hard part is
getting them to advertise your thing and
so this is where reminders reach outs
like tokens here's Starbucks just
getting them engaged messaging them to
remind them to keep doing it because the
thing is is if they promote it once
it'll help a little bit but if they
promote it consistently throughout the
whole time they're all in and the depth
that you will get with their audience
because their audience will see that
they are bought in you will carry on
some of that trust when you make your
offer for whatever it is so one of the
important things is that I have a big
list of people who are going to this
event and so I said hey it would mean
the world to me if you shared this event
with your audience so I sent two emails
to that big list and from those two
emails we got 9 000 people to say they
wanted to register now I share on my
story I shared in other places but the
majority of that came from my email list
who decided to become Affiliates and
promote it to their audiences here's a
mistake that a lot of people make is
that they will then keep messaging the
the audience that's supposed to show up
to the event to promote the event and
then they lose Goodwill in that audience
and so I opt to do two Max three
advertisements over the entire length of
whatever your campaign is to let them
know that the opportunity exists and
even within those messages I assume that
my customers are going to be the vast
majority of people are going to read
this so be smart about what you're
saying don't be like oh man we're gonna
sell a shitload of books here right like
you can't say that right like because
your customers are like that's how he
sees me right you don't want that and so
the idea is like this is going to be an
amazing event like you want to continue
to edify the event and follow the same
messaging buckets that you would about
the main thing but then tie in the why
it ties to the mission for them to also
support you and the whole cause overall
and so for us we sent two emails that
created nine thousand and then once they
get onto that list then they've given
you permission to give them way more
information but even then I tend to just
because probably my communication style
in general I tend to communicate
thoroughly but not as frequently like
some people want to email every day
that's not my vibe and so every week and
we set set the expectation up front you
will get two emails a week from me from
now until the day of the Fig and that
way they can think okay there's five
weeks I'm gonna get ten emails from it
done and then what do I do when I make
my promises I keep my promises and so I
say the first email is going to be more
content that you can then use because
I'm going to give them stuff in real
time now what did we do with the content
I told you I gave them the black book
was there any more stuff of course there
was but I didn't give it up front
because I knew that everybody's going to
take that stuff because now that's their
Insider Intel that shows that they have
more inside knowledge than anyone else
does which is why people click their
link and also gives them stronger brand
Association but then three weeks in I'm
going to give them another big packet of
stuff that they can then use so that I
can guarantee that their ads don't get
stale as they promote my thing just like
I would for myself so I would not give
them that same Advantage because I want
them to promote it and I want it to work
two emails a week one with the content
and the other with the update of where
they stand because a lot of people are
like well where am I how many do I have
and this is the part that a lot of
people don't get it's like you have to
give them tracking back now the more
advanced you are as an affiliate
marketer and people who manage networks
Affiliates sometimes you need to have
back-end tie-in so they can get pixel 5
fires and all sorts of stuff now for me
because of the nature of this event I
didn't mess with any of that because I
wanted to make it very easy very light
lift for all the Affiliates and I wanted
to be more on Goodwill and if they're
aligned with the cause more than because
they're trying to get a paycheck the
right Affiliates are also stoked about
the thing right and this is a piece that
I think a lot of people miss when they
do this is they're like if you just try
to get people for the money then it
means you've hired mercenaries if you
get people for the cause you've hired
missionaries right and you want
missionaries not mercenaries because
mercenaries will just go to the next
person who has the highest bidder and
then you basically have a reverse race
to the bottom you have a race to the top
in terms of how much you're willing to
pay them to promote your thing which is
not a type of business that I want to be
in and so I'd rather say hey you're not
going to get anything but you're going
to get all this Goodwill and if you're
associated with that or you want to
associate with that then here's a way to
do it that's fast and easy and so we
provide them even more value than the
people who are on the list in their
sphere like it's not as more value it's
different value that they would find
interesting like me explaining how I'm
doing this affiliate thing is valuable
for them so that they can use it on
their own stuff because these are all
marketers and promoters in their own
right have their own businesses and so
for them half the value is seeing what
I'm doing behind the scenes so that they
can employ it themselves I'll bet you a
third of the list of the nine thousand
are just want to see what I'm doing and
aren't even planning to promote it at
all and that's okay I'm fine with that
right but by the way if you are going to
promote go promote the tldr here is
provide value to them just like you
would a customer give them stats of
where they're at be consistent with
whatever promises you make be upfront
about the expectations that you have of
them and what expectations they can have
of you and then stick to those and then
the last week the last few days a couple
extra reminders and then you're on and
then after that you announce the winners
and you give them the prizes that you
promised and when you choreograph all
that together you might be like man
that's a lot of work well yeah but so is
so valuable is having 9 000 other people
promoting your stuff for you because if
you think about at the end of the day
there's two people who can promote what
you have you and other people and there
are more of them than there are of you
there's a lot of people in the world and
there's a lot of people who don't know
who you are and so if you can find a way
to make it a win-win win you unlock as
much traffic as you want for whatever it
is you're trying to sell and so the
win-win-win because I'm going to say
this against I think it's important is
that you have to win the affiliate has
to win and most importantly Their
audience has to win and if you can if
you can show them that Their audience
wins by them associating with you you
will unlock the doors to as much
promotion as you want and the coolest
part I'm saying this again is that this
is absolutely free anyone can do this
and all you do is you lead with value
and you have to remember that you now
have two customers you have your
Affiliates that you have to make offers
to and deliver on and Market to and
provide value to and you have the
customers yours and their customers that
you know have to deliver on and I will
tell you this the standards that the
Affiliates will have for how you treat
their customers will be even higher than
how you treat your customers and the
main thing is is because everybody
thinks they treat their customers better
than they really do and so they expect
anyone else to treat them with the
utmost respect in care having Affiliates
forces you to raise your own standards
for how you how good you are at
messaging and advertising in general
which is one of the things I kind of
like about it because it gives me a
little bit more pressure to keep over
delivering and I will tell you that
there are a couple things that I made a
couple tweaks that I made to how we're
promoting the book that I only made
after some of my closest friends were
like dude I'm gonna be pushing this to
my whole audience and I was like I need
to say this different I need to word
this differently and these tiny tweaks
that I think will give huge up huge
outcomes for us and them but I wouldn't
have done if I didn't have that next
level of pressure and so that is the
complete behind the scenes affiliate
guide of how I promoted this book 100
million dollar leads and maybe by the
time you see this we'll be at 10 000.
and real quick if you have an audience
that's big or small and you've enjoyed
the content or you enjoyed the last book
and you think that your audience or your
friends would enjoy the next book then
you can go register and actually promote
it at acquisition.com forward slash
affiliate and there's no Financial
incentive and you can tell your audience
that you have no Financial incentive for
doing it and the idea is that if they
click your link you might enter to win
but I forgot to say the last little
secret which is that if you just get
over 10 people to the event I'll give
you two bonus chapters that I'm not
going to release in the book just for
every single person who brings 10 people
to the event because it means so much to
me that I didn't put the value in the
book just to give it to you guys because
I knew that I wanted this to be special
and I wanted to demonstrate what I say
in the book in real life and now that
you understand the affiliate strategy
that I'm using to promote 100 million
here is the next video for making you
more dollars